I saw something I was not supposed to
they gave me a choice die or become a
sparrow Moscow
there's the program they call the
sparrows train to seduce and manipulate
that's what she's mrs. Anna you're like
you have a gift you see some people take
your life back I'll find a way
you always my stupid red sparrow rated-r
honey mama what is it I have to go with
Roy
I was told to take a man to hotel I said
that he was an enemy of the state take
off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she made him instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so they gave
me a choice die or become a sparrow from
this day forward you will become
space-weapons in a global struggle for
power you'll be trained in psychological
manipulation you must learn to push
yourself beyond all limitation take off
your clothes
when we are finished with you the person
you were will no longer exist every
human being is a puzzle of need we must
become the missing piece and they will
tell you anything we have a gift you
know how to survive this is what you
were meant to talk
who's the traitor in the government his
last known contact is an American good
clothesline a very simple yesterday are
we going to become friends is that what
you want sparrow the only matter cause
of what you can do for them and work
with me and make these men Hey you are
better at this than any of us
your only problem is you have a soul we
can't trust in a word that comes out of
her mouth there's some house or in a
scene
if she's compromised she will be
eliminated
you belong to them they won't ever let
you go I'll find a way
[Music]
you